okay great so people who are joining
this livestream this is going to be
hopefully a quick review of some geo
functionality for version 12 of my
garage okay so what should we start here
yes I think the main thing is to have a
look at the rough patches and we can
discuss the basic structure of these
four functions I have added a few
tentative links in the guide pages okay
so let's take a look at these functions
pure vector so these four functions is
that they are the parallel of the
Opposition the Opposition in you your
position X Y Z and the average position
and basically what they do is that the
they are vectors in the frames defined
by those position functions right and
the new thing in these functions with
respect to the other ones is that the
vectors do not make sense unless you
know where they are right so that's why
we always need to store the location
with them with them and we use the arrow
notation in order to support
simultaneously in the same argument this
idea of the array goes to array or an
array of rules what's this one we have a
throwback yes imagine that you have in
some place a location our rodeo vector
so this is basically prepare for
something in the future that we could
call a do feel or the data or something
like that that takes the locations and
the vector separately so if you have
numbers this back and you need to
express which type of vector this is
then this is accepted
I think we shouldn't say the same
collection here represents a collection
of vectors at respective geo locations
do we usually do we say that do we do we
say that for all right represents to
your vector later how about something
like that so it's associated location is
I don't like using context because it
reminds me of our contexts whose
Associated location is externally known
well how about does not need to be
specified does not need to be explicitly
specified it is implicitly specified has
been implicitly specified these these
needing to be experimental or they just
go to future items and these will be
used in various places the vector have
to have the same units well we have
three numbers there is mod horizontal
modulus bearing and vertical component
so the modulus and the vertical
component need to have the same for
example imagine a velocity yeah but but
but no it's not the same units they have
to have the same physical quantity must
have units associated with the same
physical quantity it could be miles per
hour and feet per second
yes yes you're right it must correspond
to the same physical quantity well then
we say must have compatible units fine
or no units at well or no units at all
right yes but I guess that's a
particular case of two numbers have
compatible units can have units can have
units but they must be compatible
can have can be quantities with units
but their units must be compatible
we're not quite how we normally say it
but if it gets fine okay so let's talk
about what this looks like this
extremely ugly object I've changed the
color to be the slightly darker red of
Jim okay by the way that 160 what the
heck is that that's a that's a bearing
and degrees exactly yes I can make it
returning in degrees it just sometimes
you mean in degree quant units because
otherwise it wouldn't be compatible okay
um you know one of these days there
should be an around around this okay so
then if I say so you're saying if I say
geo list plot sort of idea graphics of
that vector you just show the area yeah
okay right but now you can say point or
your marker and then it brought
something what happens I'm sorry if I
I'm confused by something let's say here
we have our two pod now
okay so those are two geo positions
right yes in journalist plot so now if
those are vectors what does it do
nothing for the moment but if you put
them in Geographics no I understand but
I'm just suggesting the cheerless plot
should do something I see
I mean I think it should make little
arrows at those things whatever the
default behavior is I mean that's the
default behavior for a Geo point geo
position I think there should be a
default behavior for a Geo vector yes of
course yes I'm thinking of the relation
with you have extra plot but your vector
plot tries to infer a full field for
sure right but that's that's correct
okay so that which is correct okay okay
problem okay but but so I think geo so
you're saying to your marker of the Geo
vector so if I say here
well you're saying Geographics of geo
marker of that that will join an arrow
okay that's fine it's fine
and now what's the scale of that arrow
exactly
so because the arrow is seen in speed it
has no relation whatsoever with there
with the scale of the back and read so
what we do and this is what the vector
product does is just decide some scale
based on the number of arrows you have
if you have many arrows they become a
bit smaller but the important thing is
that all the arrows inside the same
vector object they keep their relative
norms okay that seems good so for
example if I if I take how do I get a
geo array of points array of points of
array of geo points I wasn't gonna do
random but I could do round your
position random geopoint random position
that says it didn't some prototype thing
okay so let's say random geo position of
Illinois should it be in system okay so
something has goofed up there with the
prototype build something is still left
over the prototype thing okay so if I
say wind vector data is not so that is
another thing to fix yes so you would
have to do thread do the thread of that
I am i threading water just doing this
because normal doesn't act on geo
position we have discussed this
what's normal of your position could be
several things I do just nothing as you
were doing but threat of of your
position so it pushes the head wonderful
deeper now this is slow because each
call is slow for example geomagnetic
model data and the gravity model data
are able to get many of these points at
the same time but totally bizarre it
failed in one case yes I've reported
these to Jason ok so now if I do this
now I say I mean clearly G olace plot
should work for this but it's not going
to so right now I say Geographics of
cheer marker that's a bit unfortunate
it's scaling the scale isn't being
correctly handled by the arrows yes
there is another issue here which is
that apparently we always place by
default the arrows the center of the
arrow at the location that's wrong it
should be this should be that point of
the arrow right so we have an something
called placed start which moves the
arrow there an umbrella this opinion we
should keep the our standard to be
compatible with how this works in every
other place which is what but wrong it's
wrong for something which is rooted as a
vector that is you know we've start at
this point and you blow by the wind that
that distance that's how it should work
right I
in this bringing up to it okay
so okay
important thing here as cheerless plot
really needs to support your vector what
approach yes so the grid vector like
your grid position has a projection and
it's what happens when you have some
arrows some vectors and you project them
so yeah so for example here you just
start with two arrows which are one it's
north pointing one is east pointing zero
in 90 by the way by the way if you're
gonna draw these arrows they better not
be centered on New York right and
they're not in this case oh you cuz you
cheated here yes so this is there is no
doubt about this these arrows have to
have I mean look at this case you can
see it has to be the case okay
so please let's let's fix that okay so
in other words what it is is that geo
marker and all the default cheerless
plot of G of X should just do the right
thing with these arrows okay yeah so the
second argument supports the full
language of vector markers okay I forgot
that we had a museum um okay random zero
position we've already talked about
right yes okay all right so then the
remaining things for us to do here so
I'm I'm good with this stuff that's some
are we looking at um asked us geo vector
work in spherical geometry yes sure
that's the trivial I mean is there in
fact a a a geo model that is just
spherical
for this version I'm calling it
spherical earth maybe we should have a
one that's called unit spherical earth
is a model of the earth as fear of the
proper size right we could have one
which is just unit sphere for close-in
unit sphere
um I mean arguably oh yeah we have this
just say it's fear of radius one we just
say chill model arrow one so that makes
the sphere in fact there are some
formulas but hopefully we're going to
have eventually all of these things of
spherical position etc etc etc it's the
plan right but you can do this right now
using spherical using yes so that has a
datum as the second argument so you can
just say come on one presumably there
yes that's really nice I didn't know
that we should give some examples of
that distance of your positions to your
positions come on in both and gives you
exact so you're saying your distance of
geo position a be one use numbers it's
always samples but use exact numbers why
wouldn't it work like this I mean is
very number oriented
and so magnificent
why the tank feet because all your
models are supposed to be distances so
when we say one this is actually being
interpreted as one meter and then
because we are in the US it's converting
it to feet that's the ugly factor in
front I see but so radius are in the
case of I mean that seems very bizarre
why don't we make radius aw and it's
just a number B B if it isn't a quantity
just make it be the raw thing right yes
but for example in Geographics we say
geo range goes to 10000 that's
documented to be 10000 meters so in many
many places well that's why we need
spherical position etc etc we should I
mean that should not be difficult to add
all the stuff can be replicated in
figures geometry when do we start adding
the things that the geometry team is
adding well I think we will want I mean
you know that's been done and beyond
that nobody cares I agree I think we
should implement that so that we just
you know have a version of this that is
the mathematical version without the you
know without
degrees and radians etc etc etc I really
think that's worth doing I think
somebody you know I don't think it needs
the most sophisticated you know I think
it's a question of basically you know
piggybacking on the cheer framework on
the live stream someone was asking about
airplane flights yes no problem geo
position takes a height you can
absolutely plot that you can plot
satellites if you want to just work
coming later is relativistic Corrections
to distances and things we don't support
that yet sorry um yes by the way geo
direction distortion has always had been
renamed okay all right that's too quick
look at these guide pages if that makes
sense
Anna Michigan grab up I think
I would think we want to put cheo cheo
Derek vectors and vector frames don't we
want to put that underneath geo pods and
measures maybe not actually do like the
content counterparts of the positions
yeah okay okay looks great
okay I'm by the way for some reason that
didn't give a 12 plus they're too
you
you
don't you want to have your geo and
pause and routing don't you want to have
the things like this geo grid direction
difference wouldn't that make some sense
or is that silly make that's silly
I don't mind I think it's a bit too
technical for this page right
great where do you discuss
I'm putting scales on plots geo scale
bar or whatever it's called seven here
iog of scale bar great and don't forget
Geo scale bar obviously has to link to
those Geo grid unit distance and so on
make sense yeah
you
what is it to him why is it not finding
that it seemed at least
so here I was suggesting to add your
vector plot and your stream plot sure
perhaps also in the in the first section
of maps and cartography the first part
is is dedicated to geography
visualization so I think that they fit
their Padma yes I agree I mean just as a
listing underneath what were they um
[Music]
cheer vector plot
yeah surely we should have Geographic
geo gravity model data next section
actually is becoming quite large so
perhaps they it can be separated into a
part well history of it approaches to
employee put on Anna yes in this page
Terrell indeed
about here I just want to do I don't
think we should put that there
chill vector I don't think it's really
needed here and I wouldn't go too wild
here I would just say sure geo gravity
model seems fine to put in here should
we just put that in
um we don't have a for other plants to
it gotta have that before there's a
lunar colony but we can we've got a
while I think um okay
alright I think we're pretty much done
here I'm getting some comments on the
livestream let's let's look at these ah
wants to see how to add 3d geo vectors
something like this I had three teacher
vectors can you add 3d geo vectors what
does it even mean you do geodesy
displacement if you want to add 3d geo
vectors right it's precisely a 3d vector
yes so imagine that you have many do
vectors on the surface of the earth
because since one has its own frame how
do you relate them one another yeah
that's the role of the vector X Y Z
because it will move them all into the
XYZ frame of the earth and then you can
use 3d graphics yeah but what about
clear displacement can if you do a
displacement on a Geo vector does it
work the earth and it has to be
kilometers or miles the vector can be
velocity or acceleration I know but but
why why doesn't kill displacement move
the base point I think it should but I
think what it should do is move the base
point with the vector being parallel
transported well is it's not parallel
what is it it's it's it's it's
transported by some connection around
the earth right yes which is implemented
parallel transport in geo displacement
and then we can do that the standard
thing of transporting a vector in
closed around the closed path and and
the final vector is not someone well
that's a pretty cool picture um I wish
these borders weren't as fuzzy as they
look there I hope that I no fuzziness
has been worked on okay and there was a
lost question on the live stream will
geo scale bar update and dynamic kill
graphics very good okay let me commit
this stuff I think we are in good shape
here
okay thanks some thanks to people on the
livestream
appreciate your comments see you later